avant de mettre vos pancartes parce que
j'ai hâte de savoir si vous avez zappé
ou si vous avez mater l'épisode de koh
lanta j'ai vu que sur twitter il ya
plein de gens qui disaient faut battre
+8 pour comprendre les règles de koh
lanta sans égal et moi j'ai tout de
suite la paix puisque gt gt gt pas sur
paname
voilà c'est le grand retour de koh lanta
sur tf1
après un an et demi d'absence a nouvelle
saison du jeu s'appelle la guerre des
chefs ça a très bien marché c'est un bon
week-end pour tf1 5,6 millions de
téléspectateurs
il arrive en tête des audiences et
malgré les polémiques le programme
résiste vous allez nous dire pourquoi
est-ce que vous mater ou est-ce que vous
happer premier extrait déjà on va
revenir sur les moments forts et cette
saison koh lanta commencer par la
mythique épreuve des poteaux
habituellement c'est à la fin de
l'aventuré que les candidats doivent
surmonter cette épreuve
et là c'était au début regarde c'est une
grande première dans l'histoire de koh
lanta débuter votre aventure par la
mythique épreuve des poteaux
attention pour tout le monde sous lever
le pied gauche
troyes 2-1
catastrophe cette deuxième planète a
causé la chute de 9 naufragés la
victoire pour béatrice
1h36 bravo félicitations à midi quelle
belle finale
voilà donc ça démarre et ça a démarré
par l'épreuve des poteaux direct bonne
idée ou mauvaise idée de redémarrer par
les points des poteaux dans le vent
conditionnables saumâtre et des idées
très bonne idée ça vous a plu
moi ça m'a plu parce que ça à rome que
ça met tout de suite dans l'ambiance
c'est à dire que immédiatement on leur
met une pression ils savent
immédiatement qui sont dans un jeu non
seulement d' aventure physique mais
également de stratégie et du fait qu'il
va y avoir trois entre guillemets chefs
de tribus qui vont pouvoir en plus aller
voir dans la tribu d'à côté comment se
passent les conseils pouvoir aura
quelles informations et j'ai déjà dit
que la vie n'a rien compris
alors alors vous faire vous mettez bien
au petit port karim vous avez ou est ce
que vous mettez alors là on parle des
poteaux je suis totalement ces nouvelles
règles sur les matchs de ce que vous
avez on ne comprend rien les poteaux
avait pas besoin d'armes étaient en
général donc vous matez donc mais
pourquoi vous appelez les poteaux mais
ted en général se faisait appeler poteau
parce que les poteaux c'est mythique
c'est à la fin ils étaient 21 cents les
bornes
s'ils tombaient comme des quilles on
s'en foutait totalement voilà alors oui
c'est là bas c'est bien de changer des
poteaux parce que les halles à vous
appeler madame maintenant louis à la fin
tout le monde est à peu près affûté si
tu étais un peu ankylosé au début tu
avait maigri pendant l'épreuve inquiéter
fut une bonne condition là c'est presque
armes égales pour tous moi à la tout le
monde arrive car si j'aime bien
naïvement qu'ils osaient est là et que
tu tombes tu tombe bien qu'il a raison
et tarifs à six mois demain sur la tête
de ma mère je commençais mission par
l'épreuve des poteaux
la plus belle voix vous allez voir parce
que c'est pas les poteaux et on va voir
qui va rester et qui bat à l'émission
[Musique]
qui tombent du poteau le dernier qui
reste et je le sors directement il va
les gens voient pas koh lanta et si on
tient 1h40 qu'est ce que vous faites
ben au moins je me débarrasse de vous
dans l'émission ça peut-être croyais
vraiment vous allez tenir une heure 40
sur un poteau 20 serment ouais non voilà
donc l'inversé à part si c'est sur le
zen et a démarré par les poches de
poto-poto et dès le début de l'aventuré
moi ce que j'ai aimé c'est que ça je
vous dirais que j'ai rien compris du
tout je regardais mon frère vient donner
des notes j'étais en bac moins six bars
à commencer par une heure et demie cost
russell crowe swayze et la 8c pessoulens
avant maintenant c'est de l'action
alors dès le début de l'aventuré les
candidats ont dû se jeter à l'eau pour
rejoindre la plage à la nage
vous vous affairez compile des meilleurs
plongeons ça nous a rappelé une ancienne
émission de tf1 ont rappelé de snh du
québec après deux années d maroc
l'ossature d'un superbe tacle il est bon
que koh lanta au début du jeu vous
montrer ce que c'est et si vous venez
ils poussent leur cul sur la scène son
coup d'envoi la polenta il se tape les
mecs sains et au courage et fait près de
2 ap
parce que comme ça je peux le faire pour
vous l'aventuré s'arrête ici
j'accuse allez on est pressé je battais
leurs deux
non
[Musique]
voilà un doublé de jonathan allen gilles
verdez vous matez kolontar
à ma grande surprise parce que
franchement tout ce qui s'était passé la
polémique sur laquelle je vais vous
donner des informations ça m'avait
soufflé mais je me suis pris au jeu et
j'ai regardé
alors il faut savoir que y avait donc
une information judiciaire ouverte à
nancy les a rappelé les faits oui alors
il ya une information judiciaire ouverte
pour agressions sexuelles de la part
d'un candidat mais il dit sur candide
présumé il est bien entendu présumé
innocent bien entendu d'ailleurs pour ça
que koh lanta s'est arrêté absolument
et donc en fait les deux avocats ne
parle pas j'ai appelé le tribunal de
nancy le rôle n'a pas voulu me confirmer
mais selon les infos qu'on avec votre
équipe le procès est imminent le hac ans
et va se tenir
équipe qui payent alors la saison c est
tf1 c'est la production alors ça je
pense que c'est la production à caen
assurances n'ont pas joué mais on attend
quand même c'est suspendu quand même au
résultat judiciaire
ça va coûter combien vaut près dizaines
de millions à peu près de vous appeler
oui alors déjà pour tous ceux dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure clair que pour
moi commencer par l'épreuve des poteaux
c'est avoir choisi la facilité oui comme
si vous êtes un resto vous avez une
spécialité qu'est cassoulet et du coup
vous fait que du cassoulet moi je suis
désolé nous aurait dû se prendre la tête
et trouver une nouvelle épreuve génial à
nous faire découvrir la sphère les
poteaux les poteaux évidemment c'est que
ça marche je suis déçu dans les poumons
nous faire maintenant être polygame
sauront ils nous mettent les poteaux à
chaque épisode et n'arrivent pas à
m'attacher aux personnages parce que
j'ai trouvé ton beaucoup beaucoup trop
sportif et quand je regarde à cela les
épreuves
je suis dans mon canapé en train de visa
je me dis mais les peaux fines a remis
les candidats on a vu chloé elle a des
difficultés à nager mais n'a pas hésité
à se jeter à l'eau heureusement pour
elle d'autres candidats sont venus
l'aider à rejoindre le rivage regarder
douze ont osé sauter dans cette mer
agitée et sombre
même chloé pourtant piètre nageuse elle
a déjà des anges gardiens
chloé soulagé de recevoir cette aide
elle est loin de son quotidien
est ce que vous voulez est ce que vous
voulez qu'on soit passe pour le crif
avec vous oubliez votre avis gégé qui
l'attendait mais l'on nommé le fils oui
vous nagez dogme oui il est parti des
saillies olivier renard porte quoi elle
va rigoler c'est le conte en attaque
côté du mano magnifique
regardez ça y est j j a touché la bouée
mais ils paniquent et ils n'arrivent
plus du tout avancé chez j'ai fait du
surplace
il ne parvient pas à rejoindre le ponton
à la nage alors voilà donc koh lanta
vous à peu vous mater le premier épisode
qui a très bien marché mais c'est vrai
que sur twitter il ya plein de gens qui
disaient on ne comprend rien de rien
jimmy mohamed jimoh oui eh ben non mais
j'ai adoré en d'autant plus la séquence
de chloé qui a du mal à nager au début
je me dis mais quel lourd franchement on
va co longtemps sait pas nager et quand
on apprend que ces dames finalement été
paralysée suite ailleurs affections de
la moelle épinière etc on se dit
finalement à la re réel a réussi à
marcher elle va quant à elle nage
même si c'est pas très bien très belle
histoire que le casting est très fort on
a des gens qui ont un parcours
incroyable
la femme je suis un peu de son prénom
dont le frère est amputé et après c'est
un aléa tricia débouté aviatrice mais je
trouve que c'est extraordinaire on a des
vrais candidats hillmeyer médical et
l'homme et sur une histoire des poteaux
par exemple je pense que c'est une très
bonne idée on commence par l'épreuve
mythique tout le monde rêve faire des
bouts de chair les poteaux là tout le
monde peut le voir le fait les poteaux
et barres pas aller voter et surtout les
poteaux à la fin c'était pas très juste
c'est pas forcément le meilleur
aventurier qui gagnait le koh lanta
gagner les poteaux donc commencer par ça
et finir par autre chose je trouve que
c'est très nuageux notamment gardé mais
alors ça on les aura à la fin le poteau
il rend faire plus au déblaiement les
oracles de toute façon à la fois
également les aurais gala mais on s'est
bien régalés des poteaux oui vous savez
il ya deux éléments qui ont fait que tf1
voulait absolument les faire là c'est le
truc commercial qu'ils ont faits devant
la sorbonne nous ont placé des poteaux
devant la suisse et ils ont vu comment
les étudiants adoré adoré et le faisait
mais voilà là oui en effet
et les poteaux et gantés ils les ont
testés aux débuts dans l'épreuve qui
justement annulé l'année des relais sont
rendu compte que ça fonctionnait super
bien ils ont décidé de le reprendre pour
la vingtième saison schisme selon tv
merci merci
non mais c'est à la raison certes il est
alors il ya des candidats qui commence
bien l'aventuré piola qui ont clairement
la poisse je vous laisse deviner dans
quel camp se situe bri il a déjà un tee
shirt en moins on regarde si vous avez
regardé ça oui regardez ce qu'elle fait
là j'ai un regard non heureusement qu'on
est arrivé à 17 ans
lance une nouvelle mode chez fait la
bêtise de laisser mon t-shirt un peu
trop près du feu j'étais déçu parce que
c'était un t-shirt n'ai jamais jamais
bien si chaud en tout cas ça me fait
respirer un peu voilà je me suis pris un
peu d'air sur le sous les bras mon jeu
préféré qu'il reste
alors il ya une nouveauté cette année
c'est l'apparition des chefs alors comme
la règle des chefs est un peu compliqué
on a essayé de vous la simplifier au
maximum
regardez les nouvelles règles de koh
lanta on ne loupe l'epasa prenez des
notes chez vous c'est un truc de ouf
mois frères choix j'avais mal à la tête
et non mais je te jure vous exagérez
quoi écouter excusez moi on n'a pas tous
tes khâgne et hypokhâgne un gros pipeau
camp par ces trois chaînes ils ont le
privilège de posséder un poteau de 13 cm
qui peut les protéger cette fois lors
d'un conseil avant la réunification
ensuite dans les jeux de confort ce sont
les chefs en cas de victoire qui
choisiront la petite poignée et le fil
pour libérer la partie droite qui va
tomber pour permettre aux trois chefs et
bien de brider leur première boule tout
de suite ces chefs peuvent tous se
décevoir
et dans ce cas là il faudra faire sortir
de boules de 17 cm pour faire plus ample
connaissance
il va falloir déterminer qui fait sortir
ses deux boules en premier
ya quand même une personne à qui m'a dit
arrête de dire que tu comprends rien
parce que c'est hyper simple tu passes
pour un débile bien content j'ai rien
compris
tu disais moi mais bon apparemment elle
elle a tout compris à koh lanta l'a tous
compris à tous sains et voilà merci en
tout cas il arrive pas mais un sont
depuis 2 8 me ce tracé très bien je
fermais jean michel maire vous matez oui
oui je mal parce que c'est comme je le
dis souvent ça spectacle familial y en a
plus beaucoup approuvent cette année ils
ont des belles personnalités jouent un
beau casting toujours savent être réussi
le seul petit bémol c'est que c'est de
moins en moins un jeu d'aventuré dans ce
sens qu'ils sont fidji que tout le temps
beau y'a plus comme avant des orages
dans ses passes il était beau foot je
suis désolé c'est pour ça que tout bon
devant mac n'est pas évident voilà toute
embauche choqué les jeux il ya les jeux
là ce trio fidji je peux vous dire qu'il
ya des pluies torrentielles carimalo en
temps pour moi j'étais tranquillement en
train de pêcher si on se dit bien sûr je
pêchais aux fidji voit pas et je peux
vous dire assez pris un taureau je peux
vous dire on ajouté enfin bon c'est pas
comme façon le malheur de poissons non
mais là non pas de l'arrêt alors il ya
kho lanta c'est aussi les caractères on
a vu celui de sidi qui a
particulièrement agacé les
téléspectateurs y en a toujours eu moins
on n'aime pas dans koh lanta qui fait
défoncer à la peau c'est cindy cette
année regardez vous a fait une petite
compil du style cindy scène je le dis je
suis génial et j'ai pas peur de le dire
parce que je le démontre au quotidien
des femmes sine die
j'ai merdé aujourd'hui mais j'aurai à la
bouffe et voilà avec
derrière vérifier
manioc ou es-tu de cours ramené du
maniaque de la coco le collier
d'immunité et gecko dad
je crois que je me suis perdu il fallait
que ça marche je suis paumé
et là aussi à lorient nagl et ensuite
des corps qui est le relou de la bande
victor qui a agacé les internautes ne
l'aï pas aimée ah non il est
insupportable par hectare c'est vrai
n'avait pas accroché avec victor alors
là ben voilà écoutez basse et bouddha
cela soit dit vous vous mater ah oui
alors des victoires a particulièrement
lui aussi agacé les internautes vous
allez comprendre pourquoi tout de suite
là je pense que faire une cabane ce soir
pour vingt-et-une personnes
c'est illusoire de toute façon ne sera
pas étanche je me suis entraîné pour
faire le feu pas mal de fois je pense
que ça ira ça dont je suis sûr c'est que
les gars il ya un fromager qui l'a fait
deux fois le feu dans tout on va y
arriver
dubois dubois dubois tous leurs atouts
du bois le bois le bois du petit bois
voilà c'est fait j'ai fait le feu
j'étais sûr entraîné pour le feu je
voulais tenir mon rang je suis assez
fier bon je pense qu'on peut dire que
c'est quand même principalement sous
deux mois qu'il l'ait fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]